okay now I hope you've begun
construction there are some some really
[ __ ] li detailed things that I'm not
going to make sense just yet but I'm
going to point them out to you right now
just so we got consistency for when we
come back and there do make sense I've
got a vertical scale which is going to
give me cumulative frequency so I'm
going to put the numbers on there right
now you can see I said I was going to
start from zero and then I'm going to
count up all the way so I can make sure
I at least get to 64 so I talked out at
70 just so that I can keep numbers
around okay now on the bottom here
please pay close attention to this
because I'm going to admit right up the
gate it's weird and it's gonna feel
quite strange and arbitrary okay can you
just keep your pen in your hand even
keep it on the page but just eye up and
have a look at my horizontal axis have a
look at my markings do you notice
there's something kind of weird about
them right I have started the vertical
axis at zero and then I've just gone up
zero in fact I'm gonna write zero there
and it goes up okay but the horizontal
axis does something a bit weird okay
I'm not interested in values outside of
these I'm not interested in values
outside of these so I'm gonna start at
30 but there's this weird little gap
here it's a half column width in fact
that's so important I'm going to put a
little separate marketer for you maybe
you want to as well because the things
you think about other things you
remember that half column width I know
it seems like I said sort of weird an
arbitrary but it ends up being
surprisingly important there's a reason
it's there there's a reason we don't
just jam this up against the axis
there's a reason we don't make it a full
column will return to that idea a bit
later on for now I just want you to
register is a half column with their
from my on my board it's five
centimeters and then everything else
I've got full cons going up according to
my classes which in this case is tens
but you know there's nothing stopping
your classes being other sizes depending
on what data you are dealing with okay
all right now most of you
unlike me have a grid on your page which
will make hopefully this path or no
about to do much much easier but what we
all want to get across here is each of
these cumulative frequencies I'm going
to match with a class and then up this
scale I probably and so should you
marking what our axes are now that we
know what they are
here's cumulative frequency and then
over here are our scores so you know
scores are customarily called X right
I'm going to begin with the first class
30 to 39 I need to go to 3 right handy
for me this is 10 centimeters so I'm
just going to go up 3 centimeters you
might be 3 millimeters whatever is the
appropriate scale but the scale actually
does matter
so please measure that use your grid all
that kind of thing let's say all right
put this that's a great question so this
goes 30 to 39 and then it suddenly jumps
to 40 right we have a name for this kind
of quantitative data by the way there's
two kinds of quantitative data which one
is this one like it gives you a bit of a
clue it's discrete we're not having any
like 39.1 or even 39 and a half I guess
this is the way the HSC does it right so
I'm just treating this as the 30 to 39
category as soon as you get 40 it's a
it's a new thing ok all right so there's
my three I'm gonna mark that across I
can put a vertical line here at the left
I'm not going to put this is just a very
minor practical detail I'm not gonna put
a vertical line on the right because
it's about to be useless
the next class over has accumulated
frequency of what have a look you wrote
it down to it's nine right so just like
before I'm going to take this horizontal
line and I'm gonna draw it up at 9 for
the next class over now I just got a I
this properly so just bear with me
okay so there's my vertical line for the
next class over and you can see why I
didn't bother doing this vertical line
here because I'm just about to do one
straight over the top right yeah exactly
so I'm just going to go like so and I'm
just going to keep on going all the way
through can I ask you to do that take
great care in your measurement and your
scale and then when you're finished
maybe just way so I know where you're up
to but it'll take me a second to finish
as well so go ahead and do that now it's
okay if you're not finished I'll let you
quietly continue so so this is what
we're going to we've got our cumulative
frequencies here it's really it's such a
small thing but it's worth pointing out
mrs. Lee's had a bit of a conversation
here which I'm going to share with all
of you this looks like it's a chart that
has bars on it so it might be tempting
to call it a bar chart it's not though
it's not because number one what we're
putting onto here are classes and you
see them there are no gaps between them
right there are no gaps and that's to
indicate there's this sort of this
string of people all sort of adding up
together so we've got different kinds of
data here that's why we represent them
in different ways now
this parts also important some of you
actually have already had a go at this
question before you graphed it and you
have a graph that looks very similar to
this with some subtle differences so for
example have a look at my horizontal
values here right what are they where do
I get these numbers from I got them from
the classes importantly they are the
boundaries of the classes does that make
sense now this is not the only way that
you can take this data and graph it this
is not the only way you could take this
column that I said that I ignored later
I'm coming at you now you could take
these class centers here what is the
class center of 30 to 39 by the way 34
1/2 very good 34 and a half 44 and a
half and so on okay I'm you could make
those your markings and then your well
your blocks here would go over the
middle of those right rather than on the
edge but the reason I have not done it
like that in this case is because of
what we're about to do what we're about
to do can only be done when you graph
your classes like this not when you
your class centers anyone who has done
it with their class centers just have a
look at what we're about to do let's try
it with your other one and you'll see it
doesn't work out and this is why we care
about where you put the half column and
all that to do this Oh dive take a new
color if you've got one and very simply
all we need to do is join the bottom
left and the top right corner of each of
these bars as they go up bottom left top
right it's easy at the the first one
here's the bottom left use your ruler
again and go up to the top right so
you're gonna get that that's the first
line in your polygon I've just ruined my
40 I'll fix that in a second okay the
polygon the yoke I've is going to
continue from the bottom left up to the
top right so I'm going to go up to the
top yeah top right of each new bar okay
yeah make sense okay okay
aha very good you see already five steps
ahead of you so I'm gonna continue this
until I get to the very top and once I'm
done you can see why it's called a
polygon by the way once we're done we
will have what's called the oh guy there
it is mm-hmm now what we've got here it
tops out at 64 by the way okay what
we've got here we can use to answer this
question we had earlier about the median
and in fact not only can we use it
answer it we can do better than before
if we wanted the the median off of this
right you could get the median class but
you couldn't get the median as a score
it's the same thing with the mode okay
but we can come up with a median now
that we have our own guide that's why
these things are useful
we know it's supposed to come in at what
position 32 and a half between 32 and 33
well you can find that on your vertical
scale right 32 and a half
this is the color I will use no take it
back this is the color ideas 5:30 two
and a half that's 35 so that must be 32
and a half okay and then we can draw a
cross to where it meets the old guide
where it meets the cumulative frequency
polygon go ahead and do that I'm going
to do with my ruler because I don't
trust myself don't eyeball this do it
precisely you'll see why in a second
okay now this is important for two
reasons number one let's have a look at
where this position 32 and a half comes
to meet the bar graph okay
this answers our previous question when
we were arming and hiring over which
class the medium would appear in okay
thanks have a look it meets in this 60
to 69 class which most of you did say
before but some of you are come in
arming and hiring over this right it
should make sense because positions are
from the bottom one two and three are
here then four five six seven eight nine
are here then 10 11 12 all the way up to
21 I hear you wanted to count up to 32
and 33 just clearly in the next one okay
but we can get better than this get your
ruler again don't just draw a cross now
draw vertically draw down and you get
better than a class you actually get a
median value down here that you can read
off the graph this is why your precision
was so important okay
so go ahead again use your ruler like we
did before
[Music]
60 what what are you getting for your
median 67 68 67 68 at this scale it's
you've got millimeters right so it's
hard but um I'm um I'm really glad
number one we're getting consistency
number two that your consistency agrees
with me because I don't have grid paper
here so quietly proud of myself that my
measurements are acting up so we can say
here and I'd love you to UM mark this
year okay our median not just our median
class been our median we can read off of
our gyv I'm gonna call it at 68 okay 68
okay now if you use your class centers
and if that line that you drew
connecting things ended up falling
outside of the bars that's what happens
to you if you join up those centers what
you'll get is quite a different value so
watch out for that and you get it's it's
kind of sneaky did you have a question
or you there just just like right yeah
it's fine okay sorry I'm gonna stop
there okay
anytime you get asked for a cumulative
frequency graph and it's in classes
classes are a bit sneaky and tricky okay
but this is how to do it